I'm really glad that my favorite game in
this series is the one that had the
fully Americanized title so don't after
try and pronounce the guys Japanese name
[Music]
time for me to get self indulgent with
another why it's awesome and I'm going
back to my own video gaming history and
I'm gonna talk about the legend of the
mystical ninja i believe the japanese
name on crack
Goemon series but yeah this game is
really something else there's so much
that i love about this game and it's
hard for me to even know where to start
first of all i love the look of it i
love the visual aesthetic the sprite
work is great they are big they're
colorful they are cartooning they have
so much personality both the primary
sprites and the the enemy sprites and
the bosses they're they're really
inventive and it's primarily broken into
two main sections you've got what I
hesitate to call kind of an overworld
section but you've got the sort of
structurally a little bit like the sort
of final fight or turtles and time kind
of thing where you know you move up and
down and it's kind of pseudo 3d and you
know their characters wandering around
who you can you can kill you can get you
can fight you can killing you can get
coins and get stuff and basically you
can bum around town for a bit because in
any given sort of town there's going to
be places to explore things to find that
will upgrade you for that level and make
that level easier you don't give you
more health upgrade your weapon because
you just start with this dinky little
thing you upgrade it it's longer you
upgrade it from that and you actually
get kind of a ranged weapon out of it if
you but even that has a limit limited
range you want to go beyond that you can
throw your coins which you will actually
lose money but you can hit characters
from a completely distance you know
across the screen that way if if you're
feeling like that's what you have to do
so there are things like that and those
are the kinds of things you can do in
the overall you can collect coins you
can upgrade you can
I armor so that you can take some hits
before you start losing life you can you
can buy foods that will bring back life
if it runs out and this is all stuff
that you get to you get to hold on to so
then the other sections are the
platforming sections which are basically
you know the it's it's where it's where
stuff gets real because the the
overworld it's it's not impossible but
it's fairly hard to get killed in the
sort of town overworld sections in most
of the areas like some of the later ones
are a little tricky but for the most
part the only reason there's enemies
here is so you can kill them and get
cash and and whatever else you need so
the it's it's not there for the
challenge the platforming sections are
there for the challenge where it becomes
a straight 2d action platformer and you
know the music kicks up and is more
intense you got way more things you got
to watch out for and avoid that are
trying to or trying to kill like
explicitly because a lot of the a lot of
the quote-unquote enemies in the and the
towns they're just kind of wandering and
if you bump into the meal take damage
not a lot of them actually come after
you but you know you get the platform
sections very much not the case and then
of course there's the boss fights at the
end of all those and they are wide
ranging you fight you got a guy with a
lantern per head you've got this giant
floating head that just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger every time that you
hit it you've got you know a big octopus
which is a bit more of a mini boss
you've got all these these things you've
got these sort of sumo wrestlers you've
got the you've got the last boss this
this guy on this on this thing firing
all these arrows you've got a dragon
it's there it really runs the gamut
they're all really cool with a lot of
different tactics as to how to get at
them and that's actually that's where
your coins are going to come in handy in
terms of
that way as opposed to trying to get up
close cuz getting up close to try and
hit these guys a lot of times not the
easiest thing in the world but it's it
is fun it is precise there's a lot of
and the platform stations there's a lot
of fun done with perspective there's a
lot of rotating things so like when
something like there'll be a pole and
like there's a platform sticking out and
it rotates around now when it goes
behind it won't hold you anymore you'll
fall off it so you've got to be jumping
up so there's a lot of cool stuff done
with perspective and sort of the mode 7
capabilities of of the Super Nintendo
that just look cool and the music is a
lot of fun in this game there's also a
ton of minigames most of which are used
to earn money there's you know there's
these there's a whack-a-mole game
there's this sort of very rudimentary
maze there's sort of paint the wall game
in in there's a there's a quiz game
there's a later on you can play the
first level of gradius um there's all
these little things which I guess is
something that is not especially
atypical in in Japanese in like modern
Japanese open-world games where they're
open worlds is so much about filling in
the map and finding hidden stuff it's
more about here's all the random little
extra games that you can find and play
if you feel like it yeah I mean I have
run into that stuff another game since I
remember Final Fantasy 7 had all the
weird minigames like the like the
chocobo racing and the snowboard thing
and and stuff like that so it's it's got
a ton of that it's also two-player co-op
and so it's not it's not the alternating
you're both on the screen at the same
time and one of the thing one of the
features that I think is super cool in
the platform whatever you do two-player
co-op and platforming it can get very
tricky especially if one of you like
knows the game better than the other
because you know what to avoid
you know what traps are coming up and
the other one just keeps dying well
there's a really cool
you can do in this game one character
can jump onto the back of the other
character and whoever is on the bottom
is doing the the running and jumping the
other ones doing the attacking so if you
if you're playing with a friend and one
of you knows the game better than the
other the one who's having more trouble
in that say she could just hop on their
back and get piggybacked along to B so
that you can both get to the boss and
you're not left fighting the boss solo
because your companion didn't you know
didn't make it through the platforming
bits I think that's really cool and I
wish what games didn't did something
like that again and it does it does
hamper you slightly because now the
other guy has to do the attacking but
that's I think that's a really cool
option and I really I never stopped
being tickled by that it's a cool image
besides it's just fun and funny and
that's kind of this game this game
became for me very much an unwinding
game you know at the at the end of the
day if I just if I just had a bit of
time to kill on a weekend like a couple
of hours to feel like I'll play bitter
I'll play a bit of legend of the
mystical ninja because it's just fun and
it's funny and even even when it's hard
I never got angry at it I never got
frustrated with it and I have beaten
this game all the way through and so I
don't think it's SuperDuper hard but
there there is some decent challenge to
be had in it and there's and there's a
surprising amount of depth for what is
basically just a an a side-scrolling
action combo action platformer game and
just overall the game feels like it
feels like a product of a bygone era
because even these days when games sort
of call back and get nostalgic for
16-bit they get this idea of something
real specific you know they go in for
the the shoot-'em-up the the bullet
hell's the you know your your Contras
your your castlevanias your Mega Man's
your whatnot switch do one thing really
specifically and that's not unfair
because by and large when you sort of do
this mix of gameplay more often than not
some of it suffer
because you're not focusing on one thing
and so all of it could be a little bit
better and you're just sort of thinly
spread and that really doesn't feel like
the case here this has a surprising
amount of variance and yet it all works
like it's all and I would recommend any
of it and yet at the same time because
it does shake it up as the game goes
along and it switches between the town
sections to the to the platforming
sections and the boss fights it keeps it
from getting stale because I think if it
had been only one of those styles if it
had only been an action platformer or if
it had only been the sort of final fight
style thing I probably wouldn't love it
the way that I love it now it's the
pacing of that feels perfect feels
absolutely perfect to break up these
sections with this other section and
just keep it fun and fresh and it makes
you want to see the next section not
just because you know what will the new
enemies be what will the new platforming
challenges be it's like well what's the
new contrasts gonna be you know it's
like well what's the town gonna be like
then what's the platform we're gonna be
it's like a whole new world of things to
see and open up with each new setting
and the settings aren't even that
drastically different it's like you're
in a town you're in a carnival you're in
another town you're in the woods you're
on a lake you know it's they're not that
drastic in shifting and changes but they
still it still feels like it shakes it
up each time just because of the added
change that the the gameplay switch has
I love this game and I get the sense
that it's it's pretty well loved among a
certain section of people I just don't
know if it's up there with the majority
of folks my age of Super Nintendo gamers
but I love the heck out of this game I
really I truly have nothing to complain
about with this game I love it and I
think legend of the mystical ninja is
just awesome
so have you ever played this game what
are your thoughts on it if you haven't
played it what is your own person
sort of multiple style of levels of
gameplay type game I mean some other
things off the top of my head actraiser
be the first one be another good example
of something like this so do you have a
favorite game like that whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it there's
stuff to do you know what it is there's
buckles and there's links and there's
things there's a patreon that's all down
in the description so check it out if
you want to and remember folks you're
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
yes you're slime is it a turtle no oh
it's a dog is this the head you so
chubby the tail now does it go on the
dark yeah cool nice work if you want to
try to see it in the closet again hold
the plate out in the quad that NCSA
clothes okay can I show people this yeah
so that this is this is the putty dog
lay laying on its stomach head doing
certain eggs
that's a tail awesome okay yeah let's
check it out in the closet real quick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]